I often talk about why I think it's more
valuable to move first into a new space
the disproportionate value of jumping on
a platform early on has enormous
benefits let me explain
email marketing I built my first
business my wine business on email
marketing do you know what my open rate
for Wine Library calm was in 1996 for
the 400,000 person email list high 80s
now they're in the 20s
I got a disproportionate value of
jumping on email marketing because
nobody else was doing it at the time
right email marketing really collapse
into five in the last 3-4 years why
marketers ruined it and so when nobody
else is ruined it like marketers ruin
everything we talk about that then
you're getting bigger ROI value as I'm
doing this right now I'm being filmed on
meerkat stuff on show it I'm being like
Lou is sitting here taping me on meerkat
because it's a platform that's like
seven days old and I'm live streaming it
meerkat or something like it wins over
the next six months thirty six months
from now
even though I'll have way more people
following me on the cat less people will
be watching this stream because the
people that are watching right now it's
a novelty it's new its first mover
advantage and I'm getting the
disproportionate value specifically
talking about meerkat there's a
leaderboard and every time somebody goes
there I'm in the top six seven eight and
they see me and that gives me the
position there's a lot of people
discovering me through it and I get the
value I did that on email marketing I
did that on banner advertising on Google
AdWords on putting out a YouTube show a
year be within the year that YouTube
came out that disproportionate value and
attention Twitter on and on and on
everybody sits around and says well I
don't want to invest my time or money
into snapchat a year or two ago I'm
jumping in there and trying to figure it
out everybody is ripples by like what if
this is a waste of our time what if this
is a waste of our money what if it
doesn't become big what if it ends up
like MySpace
I say it's risky to not jump in there in
case it explodes defense defense defense
be fast be a first mover take the
learnings even if the platform doesn't
become a big deal so listen I'm gonna
keep being first I'm gonna keep tasting
those fruits I just think you should too